it gets stupider it really does because
not only do they lie about everything
but then these ridiculous organizations
like the NAACP which used to be good
right they were good organizations that
were out there that were fighting for
True equality and that were fighting for
free speech and American values but they
become all of these organizations they
become patently Lefty Progressive whack
job uh non-profits so the NAACP you are
not going to believe this what if you
have not heard about it they have issued
a warning to black people not to visit
Florida yes that's right and a reporter
asked the governor about it over the
weekend yes one more uh Governor uh the
Florida chapter of the NC
double ACP voted yesterday to ask
National Branch to issue a travel
advisory for black
Americans you know advising them not to
come into Florida over uh the AP
African-American history controversy
what a joke
what a joke yeah we'll see how we'll see
how effective that is you know just
remember
during covid these people would be on
CNN all this stuff Slam in Florida
saying we were so bad don't go to
Florida and then they would end up being
spotted on the beach somewhere
vacationing in Florida so this is just
ridiculous I mean
foreign
yes you guys get it's patently
ridiculous I should note that I had
lunch with a black friend in Miami on
Saturday we both had grouper sandwiches
actually it sounds like a joke a black
guy and a gay guy walk into a restaurant
in Florida nobody attacked us it was no
we didn't get banned or bunched DeSantis
didn't send out his goons black guy
don't talk about racism gay guy don't
get married it's all so stupid
oh
[Music]